I have to be careful with our CEO you
know it's always very important to to
take care of her
Thank You Susan for your kind
introduction good evening - ladies and
gentlemen it's a pleasure to see so many
of you tonight our gala as you have
understood is dedicated this year to
hopes and dreams for Europe so it's a
big program first let me reassure you at
mme you we are not only doing tonight we
are dreaming all the year but tonight is
a special evening for dreaming even more
we do so also dreaming I mean a bit more
at the end of a lady of a legislature
like - now but also we are dreaming at
the beginning of a new mandate so let me
tell you briefly on behalf of our 150
members our vision for the European
Union our companies are committed to
Europe and I will just give you two
numbers for your consideration US
companies employ 4.8 million people in
Europe 8 times the population of
Luxembourg
these are these are these are many many
great people in US companies on in
Luxembourg so our companies have been
operating in Europe for decades and are
here to stay
we are stakeholders not only
shareholders we want to support the
attractiveness of the EU as well as make
sure that Europe remains one of the best
places in the world to leave to work
study and raise a family now allow me to
share with you our hope and dream for
Europe many of us all of us will have a
lot of hope and dream that I share one
of you for you and it's very simple
actually it is keeping peace and
prosperity in Europe on a personal note
it is building on the memories of my 90
years old father as well as my thinking
about the future of my eight-year-old
daughter so we are all on duty to keep
peace and prosperity in Europe but to
make dreams come true
we need more than just words we need
action and in fact a time Shammi you we
have for you for all of you I will
agenda for action with four priorities
very briefly one empowering people so we
focus on people our companies to the
single market boosting the single market
which we do a lot with the Commission
and with the MEP s leading global
cooperation and here we think obviously
about the yuan the u.s. relationship but
we are thinking about so about achieving
the United Nations sustainable
development goals like we discussed last
week in New York and last last but not
least is of course investing in the
future with a budget for innovation also
to make dreams come true
beyond action we need collaboration on
partnership and indeed that we all know
no one can deal alone with to the
challenges so we need business we are
mainly here business we need civil
society all of us but we need government
to work side by side we need all
stakeholders and you can count on
as Susan said you can count on I'm Sammy
you as a trusted partners talking about
partnership or the spirit of partnership
this brings me to another reason why we
are gathered here tonight while here to
hanno a true European was dedicated his
entire career to public service
jean-claude Juncker here tonight so you
can I think we can applaud and give it a
run out for the present
[Applause]
now let me tell you a bit more about why
we decided to recognize president
younger we live in an increasingly
complex and divided world such a reason
why our societies need built bridge
builders more than ever
bridge builders are exceptional
individuals who are able to connect with
those who may disagree find common
ground and build consensus ultimately
they make a real difference because they
bring people together within a junker we
consider that you are one of them
definitely so on behalf of our members I
would like to recognize your
extraordinary achievements over the
course of your junior first you maintain
and strengthen the unity of the Union
you invested a lot of time in reaching
out to the European citizens you on your
wall college travel to the regions of
Europe to make the case for the Union
second point you also demonstrated an
unwavering commitment to the
transatlantic relationship as you can
imagine mr. president this is a call
that is very close to our hearts here
tonight you are outstanding
diplomatic skills and personal efforts
were instrumental in the escalating
tensions between the you and the u.s. in
this respect as we all know the John's
statement of July 2018 is only one
example of your leadership and you work
to solidify this relationship on this
partnership now we agree there's still
some work to do but we are immensely
grateful to you efforts Monsieur
president I would like to invite you to
join me on stage to receive this special
award which is the MMU bridge builder
award mr. president
[Applause]
so I have maybe to take your wall
so this mr. president he so what is of
course to recognize your significant
contribution particularly with regard to
as we said to the unity of Europe and to
the transit relationship if not the
Luxembourg bridge but it looks like a
great bridge it's a suspension bridge as
we say and we felt it this was a perfect
metaphor
Ayelet the flow to the present thank you
good idea
dear Suzanne shamak at maximum dear
members of the European Parliament
ladies and gentlemen I was starting this
morning a quarter past five and II and
it looks like that but nevertheless it's
a real pleasure to be here tonight I'm
told that I have always to start my
speech by saying that I'm happy to be
there it's not always true but tonight
is - because we needed yes to come
together although I was watching with
sympathy from far but it's better to see
you live and in colors it's a pleasure
to be here tonight because I'm honored
to receive this award this award is
important to me because it symbolizes a
lot of what I have tried to achieve the
last five years
in fact all my life I must say that
building bridges is not a one-man job
although one cannot succeed alone that
must be support from every side building
bridges arrived in politics or in
business is about people and about
personal relationships the first thing
to know about our transatlantic
relations and what makes it so special
special is that it is first and foremost
the friendship allow me to tell you a
story close to my heart not far away
from where I was born in Luxembourg I
know that you have more employees that
Luxembourg has inhabitants it doesn't
matter the quality is what matters
a Luxembourg is the only Grand Duchy
worldwide the only one and I'm always
telling the Russians and the Chinese
why did Luxembourg never attack China or
the former Soviet Union there is one
simple reason we don't have space enough
enough to put the prisoners in so don't
confuse size and quality not how I was
born in Luxembourg is a small town
called built during the Second World War
Wil's was hit very hard during the
battle of the bulge bulge which for the
Americans was the deadliest single
battle of the Second World War when
wills was liberated a young corporal
from the US Army's 25th 28th Infantry
Division called which bookends decided
to bring cheer to the children of the
town by the Russian up as Saint Nicholas
that day in December 1944 mr. Brookings
became a hero for the people at Will's
he was such a replica of hope for a town
that had lost everything mr. Brookings
went back to Vil's many times to fulfill
his duty as the Americans in Nicholas
just three years ago at the age of 49 he
was awarded the highest military honor
the Luxembourg by the way the likes of
President Eisenhower Winston Churchill
and Charles de Gaulle in the city
cottage mr. Perkins was part of its
important important to remind ourselves
of stories like this the people wills
like so many other Europeans have a very
special and profound friendship with the
United States of America
the second thing to know about the
friendship like ours is that it was
always something that we can learn from
each
the United States and the European Union
are the biggest economic powers in the
world we are allies and we often think
alike but also regularly disagree with
each other and sometimes have a very
different political economic or social
agenda this is why we need to build
bridges over the years I have traveled
to us many times and I haven't met with
number of presidents as a veteran
President Clinton President Bush
President Obama and now President Trump
I remember my first visit to the White
House in August 95 I was done a rather
young prime minister President Clinton
had been in office for over two years
and he said please could you explain
your to me I was trying I said it's
understandable but it works
and I started to explain through Bill
Clinton the economic monetary union the
internal market stuff like that no no
what about Turkey
when will Turkey become a member of the
European Union in 95
- his bigger progress in the world and
on that very point but I have discovered
over the years every American president
wants to know how Europe works when they
are about half with with that hat by the
end they know us better than we know
ourselves in June last year I met with
President ramp at the White House and as
a gift I offered him a photo as a
military seaman to be in Luxembourg
where General Patton is buried under
well Donald let us remember our common
history and I mean I wanted to remind
president Trump that I was there as a
friend and by the way this American
Cemetery in Luxembourg has been given as
a gift as a territory to the US if a
small country like the one dodgy is
often part of its territory to the
leading nation of the world you can see
what friendship really means we did not
do it with Germany for obvious reasons
we didn't do it with Belgium for
understandable reasons because Belgium
is preventing Luxembourg from having a
free access to the oceans and we didn't
do it with France and we would have had
good reasons to do so I also wanted him
to know that when the European Union
stands on the international stage we do
so with the backing of every member
state and of our five million citizens
that at least the explanation I'm giving
to the West president's panel at the
White House this is how the European
Union does business and I was in in
Washington last year in July to do
business at that point we agreed to
launch a new phase in the transatlantic
relationship for example we agreed to
strengthen our cooperation on energy and
to increase trade in several areas and
we are sticking to our words a year
after my meeting with President rump
European Union has increased its import
of liquid gas natural gas from the US by
over three hundred and fifty percent and
us has become newbs number-one supplier
of solids we are delivering only what we
agreed to do as friends and partners
this tells the story of a relationship
that can work for both of us
and at a time when stability comes at
the premium we must hold on what that
works this is the third thing to say
about the friendship like ours we both
need it we share the same challenges
from climate change and migration
to peace and security we have different
views on some of these issues but that
should never prevent us from looking for
global solutions today
our economies are more intertwined than
ever before which which roughly one
trillion dollars worth of goods and
services every year with each other this
is not nearly a third of the global
trade the president is always saying
that the balance between Europe and us
is not fair when it comes to trade he
forgets to mention that if you include
financial services in the comparison the
picture is totally opposite I'm telling
him this again and again and again he
listens but he doesn't believe it so
when I was at the White House in July I
was mentioning these figures and he said
I don't trust your figures I said these
are the figures of the US administration
please believe them but wait is so much
more than simply numbers trade is about
people's livelihoods and jobs trait was
our easy to start but escalate quickly
and usually end badly whoever is
starting a trade war will end badly in
his own camp Europe will always defend
free and fair trade based on a level
playing field and reciprocity we will
not be naive but we are ready willing
and determined to business and if
someone is imposing tariffs on our
aviation sector will do exactly the same
exactly
the same ladies and gentlemen I believe
there is no better place for you and for
your company's eight times the number of
Luxembourgers this is nevertheless a
good place for Europe and for your
companies to do business here in you is
a pleasure yes it is to receive this
award tonight and all of you here at the
American Chamber of Commerce are
yourself building bridges day after day
between American companies and their
European counterparts this the world in
fact is yours our continents have been
through thick and thin together through
different political cycles but our
friendship runs deep just ask the people
of wills the American European
friendship is not about hopes and dreams
is a necessity thank you for listening
[Applause]